So you know these are city planners who built to last.
I mean downtown Turin has about a megaton
of these surviving 400 year old baroque buildings
They are very hard to destroy.
They're mostly brick.
Because brick absorbs cannon fire.
But there's some marble.
Even by military standards, these are some
alarmingly stout urban structures.
Some of them get abandoned for 100 years or more.
They don't fall down. They don't rot. They don't collapse.
They just silently endure they're like Egyptian pyramids.
And eventually people show up again.
And they tend to just loft them out.
So now they're all over the place.
They're not aristocratic buildings, of course.
They're museums, archives, hospitals, cultural centers, grocery stores, tourist attractions...
Futuristic planned palaces that just won't go away.
They just don't wear out that's why their futuristic.
It has been there all the time.
And I have one of my own now.
I've got some postcards of my pet Turinese
375-year-old palace. Oh yeah, thank you, Stewart.
Yes, that's our latest Turinese renewal project.
"The Phoenix Renewed".
We're trying to find a new tenant who will move into
and renovate this palace.
This tenant needs to stay there for about 60 years. They're trying to find a guy with some staying power.
It'll take about $150K to maintain the palace
and it's gardens which are very extensive.
It's like four stories high. But it basically has about the same square cubic meterage as your odd building here.
You're in a stuffed animal building of some kind.
And this is a similar thing.
It's got the volume of your thing, but it's just...
it's baroque and it's 17th century.
And it's got like paintings and statuary
and chandeliers and carpets.
And that's our writer office.
We were done with our house of the future project
in our factory.
When we got this call from the local cultural foundation
who are called the Company of Saint Paul:
the Compagnia di San Paolo.
They're a non-governmental enterprise in Turin. An NGO.
And hey're 500 years old.
They've been around half a millennium.
So these guys are running this 500 year old charity
and they happen to be fans of ours.
It turns out they really like to read science fiction.
So they asked us if we would leave our house of the future and do a video to advertise one of their palaces.
To attract possible new tenants.
Because they manage this brick palace
which is up in the hills.
And it's called the
"Delightful Vineyard of the Royal Madame"
("the vineyard Madama Reale"). It's a place
with a rather checkered history.
It turns out that this palace/villa, our new office,
was built by and for a guy who was one of
my favorite Turinese historical characters.
I didn't realize it was actually his palace.
Until we'd like moved into the place.
But I consider him a kind of ultimate
Turinese historical character.
I know a lot about him.
He's a super interesting guy to me.
I just never expected
that he would become my landlord.
So we went into this baroque palace and they gave us the formal tour of the entire thing top to bottom.
We went up the attic which is this
amazing looking crooked garret.
We said, wow, what a fantastic office
for creative writers.
And actually the entire building was a historical archive
that was its most recent use. Mostly it was stuffed full of 500 years of financial records. Centuries of them.
Just all over the place. Financial banking records.
But it was empty because the archivist had
digitized the records and they'd left the place.
So it was record free, and they
were looking for a new tenant.
So we volunteered. We moved in. We don't reside
in our palace. We certainly can't afford it.
There are no bedrooms in there. But when we're in Turin
we commute to our palace at 9am.
And we go up to the attic. We plug in the old computers. And we have at some creative writing
in the palace and then we leave promptly at 5pm
because they lock the whole place up electronically.
And we go back to our actual apartment which
is in a completely different area of Turin.
We don't rent the palace. They don't pay us to be there.
Just kind of a friendly understanding.
We're just residents in the palace.
I'm the "Visionary in Residence" at the Villa Abegg.
And you know we write novels about Turin.
And except for one security guard,
bored guy downstairs reading sci-fi novels,
we are the only people in this huge ancient building.
We're just like the modern ghosts
in the 375 year old structure.
It's just us and that statuary and the priceless paintings and the chandeliers...
and the giant carpets and the many other relics
and the huge weedy garden and the secret tunnels...
and the weird lake with the opera set on a little island...
and a greenhouse and big urns
that are shrouded in ivy...
And it's not a house of the future,
but it is our palace of the past.
When we're not around we really kind of miss it.
It's surprising how quickly you can
get used to palatial surroundings.
I know this sounds rather comic: the sci-fi writer
is marooned inside the ancient palace.
It's like an Italo Calvino story, right?
It's oxymoronic. It's got a lot of trick reversal
kind of stuff going on.
But it is certainly the weirdest thing
that ever happened to me in Turin.
And it has some element of karmic retribution.
It's like, you're a guy, a futurist,
and you claim to be outside of time.
You have some some higher understanding
of historic processes.
And you even have the power to do weird things
in empty factories.
Because you can convince people to help you.
But that car Factory is merely 100 years old.
You should try some of your cheap futurist magic tricks with this other building from another pace layer entirely.
375 years old!
UNESCO World Heritage Age.